TEAR.
26 POINTS LAST 15 GAMES, BEST
ADAM PELECH INTERCEPTS THAT,
GUYS?L
>> Rick: THANK YOU, RYAN.
COLI THINGS START TO
HEAT UP A LITTLE AT SCOTIABANK
HANIFIN.
HANIFIN, ANDERSSON, ALL THE WAY
ACROSS THE FOR THE
ISLANDERS.
ANDERSSON BACK IN AGAIN, A DUMPN
KNOCKED OFF HIS STICK.
FED IT BACK TO THE LINE.
POSITION, THE
HIGH SCREEN AT TIMES.
YOU CAN SEE HE JUST MISSES.
AN ISLANDER.
KYLINGTON LEAVES IT.
GAUDREAU IS BACK ON BY
JOHNNY GAUDREAU.
HE DOESN'T'T SO
THEY ARE GETTING PRODUCTION FROM
THE BACK END AGAIN TONIGHT.HAT
THE CROSSBAR, WENT OFF THE
SHOULDER ONE WAY OR THE
DUMPED DOWN THE ICE BY CIZIKAS
AND THAT WILL DO
HIS STICK WAS TIED UP BY
LINDHOLM, AND NOW TKACHUK WITH
THE PUCK AGAIN,ACHUK WILL DROP .
BEAUVILLIER,
RUSH.
ZADOROV HUSTLES BACK.
NOW THE FLAMES HAVE A CHANCE THE
OTHER WAY AS COLEMAN IS ON THE
PUCK.
LATE IN THE SHIFT, THOUGH, HIS
THE FORECHECK, ZADOROV FALLS  F
BACKLUND AT CENTRE.
PUTS IT ON GOAL.
LINE WITH A PAS
DOWN LOW TO HANIFIN IN FRONT OF
IN.
BOTH TEAMS START A CHANGE.
SIX AND A HALF
UP THE MIDDLE FOR BARZAL, AND
THAT IS OFF THE MARK AND
GUDBRANSON.
SHOOOO BE ONE OF THE DEBATES
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
AMONGST EACH OTHER, BUT A IT
HAS TO BE DEFINITIVE, AND THE
ONLY THING WOULD BE SCOTT
MAYFIELD.
LUCIC CLOSEN'S SHOT BLOCKED BY
PAGEGERNER.
BACKLUND, GUDBRANSON, PLAY IT
CHRIS  PLAY,
GET THE PUCK DOWN DEEP, SET IT